Okay.
Who's calling today from the six oh two area
code caller from six O two.
Hello? Yes.
Hi, I'm Julia.
Um, I'm originally from the Netherlands.
I'm calling spring.
Come from Arizona.
Has lived here for over four years now.
Great.
Julia, if you can speak up a little bit, that
would be very much appreciated.
Oh, okay.
I'm using, I'm using earphones.
I didn't have to be on speaker.
Does that work?
Yes.
What's your question today?
Okay.
I was wondering about, um, I'm very left wing
obviously being from Europe, but I was wondering
about voter Id laws, uh, that the last week
perspective here because to me in the Netherlands
that's like that's a normal thing.
Everyone has an id.
Everyone's required to have an id from the
time they're teenagers.
Yeah, I mean so everything was completely
different in the Netherlands.
So I understand what you're saying and I understand
that there is a sort of very simplistic case
to be made that like, listen, the ids are
free and just everybody needs an ID in.
That's it.
But unfortunately in, in reality in the United
States it's been extremely politicized in
the United States, not everyone automatically
gets these ideas when they're teenagers and
us as adults, you are required to, to present
other documents which themselves do have costs
associated with them.
And so I get what you're saying.
In the Netherlands, the Netherlands is functioning
far better on this issue than the United States,
but it's not equivalent for that reason.
I was just kind of curious if she can, um,
explain to you there the case for why, why
here in America?
It is a, it does lead to a voter voter suppression
to ask for ideas where
when we've done a long form deep dive on this.
So we did, there's a lot tied into this, but
this is part of the package of voter suppression
that the right has very to differing degrees
of success, uh, um, uh, perpetuated in the
United States.
And we've dealt very, very specifically in
detail with it.
So I'm not going to go through the full scope
of it now, but you're right, within a European
perspective, how is it that just requiring
an id can be a form of voter, but unfortunately,
uh, it is here in the United States and we've
got a bunch of videos on the youtube channel.
Yeah,
really appreciate your call.
That does it for today.
Thanks to everybody who called and apologies
to everybody.
I did not.